so um uh welcome to the class uh welcome
to the uh last week of lectures um so
for today um we have a very exciting uh
topic that REI sing who's an assistant
professor atel he's a alumni from my
research group here at Stanford and uh
through through through this class we
learned a lot of uh methods that RS
developed so uh the graph Sage is his
work uh the the recommander system stuff
we work we talked about is Rex's work
today um he will talk about
explainability for uh graph based
machine learning that is his work um and
uh the graph generation we talked about
I think he also had his fingers in there
so a lot of actually topics that we we
talked about in the class were um papers
and areas p neared by Rex um so what Rex
is going to talk to you about today is
uh
explainability for graph neural networks
and how do we think about this kind of
uh explainable AI trustworthy machine
learning in the context of graph machine
learning so it be kind of a good nice
overview of that
area thank you
thank okay hello um yeah I think
everyone can hear me so uh yeah it feels
really nice to be here again I was here
until uh end
of uh but yeah like it feels great to
come back to Bara again and today I'm
going to share uh with you guys some
exciting research in the area of
trustworthy de plany especially uh
explainability in the context of GNN and
graph learning uh okay so uh let's get
started um so yeah the title of the talk
is uh XI for graphs and XI is a very
common terms to uh uh describe like expl
uh explain aable AI um and and today
we're going to focus on graph and jnn
okay um so U before the lecture I
usually give like a list of readings so
we um so I suggested something that are
uh you know more General uh um uh
explainable models such as lime and sha
U and I also posted some reference to
Jen explainer and explainability
taxonomy and uh trustworthy gen and so
some of these are from the lab uh uh
that your Elites and some others are
from uh other universities that uh give
a good overview of what explainability
is especially in the context of gmn okay
so um before I dive into explainability
I also want to uh talk a bit about uh uh
trustworthy graph learning in general uh
because explainability uh in my opinion
is uh really Inseparable from most other
uh trustworthy uh context or trustworthy
um research Topics in Ai and and GNN as
well so it covers broadly covers a wide
range of topics from explainability
fairness robustness privacy basically
any kind of issues that uh uh would
arise if we were to let the model to run
on like Mission critical scenarios or
when people are uh uh like human
decision makers are involved in working
together with the Deep Learning System
right and and uh there is a a there are
big challenges for graph learning right
in the context of graph learning a lot
of these problems become especially hard
um so uh the role of graph topology is
of course a key role uh when we talk
about graph learning right we always
talk about you know message passing
structur subgraphs you know things like
that those are important uh components
that can uh contribute to uh model
prediction model robustness and so on
but existing techniques that are common
for deep learning usually wouldn't
capture those right and also it becomes
especially hard when those topological
structures are involved if we were to do
quantitative evaluation so this lecture
is pretty much a kind of a some uh
introduction of some works that try to
solve these kind of challenges okay so
the big picture is basically like this
so uh I feel like in an area of
trustworthy Dey uh two very important
topics are what we care about like
adversary robustness and expandability
and mostly other topics like privacy
fairness and compy all all these are
usually uh you know um borrow or like
are bu buil upon existing techniques in
robustness and
explainability okay and and each of
these aspects play a very critical role
in gaining trust from users of deep
Learning Systems you know from industry
users to Academia to CS researchers even
to domain experts from uh like inter
disciplinary research where we apply
deep learning to say the field of
biology physics uh or other scientific
uh uh disciplines right and uh I as I
mentioned in uh um that the the
challenge of the in the GNN context is
that the the role of graph topology
plays a key role and we need to quantify
you know how much the topology is
contributing to explaining a model or is
contributing to robust model and we need
the quantitative evaluation okay so uh
today um I will first uh give a brief
introduction of what explainability is
because uh some um um not everyone might
be familiar with the term um and we'll
talk about the problem setting
especially in the context of graphs and
uh in the second part I will discuss
genic explainer which is one of the very
widely used uh algorithm for explaining
uh gen and predictions right now um and
in the third part I will talk about
evaluation right so I will talk about
you know uh in the in cases where you
know ground truth are not U available
which is often the case right uh like if
you want to explain a model you don't
always know like what the model is doing
right what you don't know what should
the ground truth explanation be right in
those cases how can we evaluate the
performance of explainability and you
know there are actually like multiple
Dimensions where we can uh say whether
an explainability method is of a higher
quality versus a lower quality okay so
that's the um uh three aspects and and
we'll start with the uh explainability
uh and its problem study so we'll talk
about motivations goals and settings
that we typically care about and some of
it or most of it actually applies to you
know many many other fields of deep
learning as well and I'll talk about
that and I'll talk about the specifics
of in the context of graph money okay
right so the key concept or the key
problem with uh any kind of trustworthy
uh deep learning aspects including
expandability is that uh uh it has this
blackbox nature which I I think by now
every one of you should be familiar with
right so um blackbox nature basically uh
means that you do not know uh what
exactly is the model using as the uh
important parts of the input that
decides the uh prediction of the model
right and and understanding or being
able to open the blackbox is essential
um and um explainable AI or XI is an
umbrella term for any research that
tries to solve this uh blackbox uh
problem for AI right and why is it
useful uh first of all right it en
enables user to understand the decision
making of the model right uh it not only
knows that the model magically outputs
this prediction but in uh like we want
to know why it goes from this uh how it
arrives at the the answer right given
the input um it also helps us to gain
trust from Human users of the deep
larning system right uh imagine that you
know you are collaborating with a domain
expert in say uh biology and and they
want to know you know whether their
knowledge in biological sciences is
going to be applicable and it's actually
being captured in the Deep learning
model and that's super important um I
also listed an archive paper on like a
simple to read guide uh so this is for
General explainability so if you are
interested in this area in general you
should definitely have a look right um
but uh we're talking about um
expendability for deep learning right uh
so um and and we said it's especially
hard because of the blackbox nature but
uh let's try to remember you know what
was explainable right when we talk about
the classical machine learning methods
and maybe you know we can borrow some of
the insights there to the uh to to in
order to explain the Deep learning
models okay so uh maybe let's have a
quick Capt uh recap of what was
explainable right so um if I to think
about you know something that was
explainable the first reaction that I
had was uh linear regression right
that's like the most uh uh fundamental
method you can ever think about in like
statistics and computer science right so
you have some kind of prediction that is
called y right and then you have some
input features X1 X2 X3 and all that
right um and then you have some weights
linear weights associated with each of
these input features so we call them W1
W2 and so on and this was extremely uh
uh explainable just because you know you
can have a plot here right so you know
you fit this data into like a line right
a linear model um and and because it is
linear you can naturally Define this
slope right um so this this green arrow
here um so it basically corresponds to
each of these weights right imagine that
your x- axis is one of these axes like
let's say X1 and your y- axis is
actually your prediction y right so your
slope uh directly indicates you know how
important uh uh uh the the feature X1 is
to the output right um you know if the
slope is very steep that means the
feature is actually critical for the
model right it's uh it has a large
coefficient if this slope is very uh um
flat uh you know this feature is
basically not going to influence your
prediction at all right so um you know
we can have some kind of explanation
like this you know a change in Delta x
amount to let's say feature X1 is going
to result in an increase in prediction
by y amount right and Delta y amount so
uh that kind of uh sentence can tell us
you know how important a feature is
right but this is not so easy in in deep
L model as you would imagine right there
isn't even a slope here okay the second
thing uh intuition I would have was uh
kind of Dimension reduction right that's
again like one of the most fundamental
models uh you know we have some data in
a very high dimensional space we project
them down into like low dimensional
manifolds um and then you know we can do
a kind of like clustering we can
importantly can care about decision
boundaries right let's say we have uh
the red classes and the green classes
and and we can draw those decision
boundaries some mods gives linear
boundaries some models give access Aline
boundaries some models give you know uh
non-trivial boundaries right and and in
deep learning this kind of boundaries
can be very uh complicated but it's
something that we want to understand in
order to explain a deep learning model
OKAY the last thing I want to talk about
in terms of what was explainable a kind
of decision tra right again it's like
something you would imagine um it's
extremely uh like self- explainable like
I I would say like you don't even have
to have some kind of additional things
uh to think about right like let's say
you have a decision tree you know you
you know exactly what uh you know each
feature plays a role in the decision
tree right you know uh we can say
something that is um kind of at the
aggregate level right for example if the
condition of some kind of node is met
let's say the node is the pedal length
of this U Mach is classical data set the
pedal length is less than 4.75 uh it is
likely 80% of the times it is likely to
be classified as true right so it's just
like a direct consequence of dentry
right okay so now like having Revisited
you know some of the traditionally very
explainable models the question now is
you know how can we uh bring some of
these or retain some of these
explainability when we transfer to like
a deep uh version of the model right and
and indeed there are many ways to uh do
that right in the general field of uh
expandable uh Ai and uh uh typically you
know corresponding to like the slope the
linear regression slope that I talk
about there are uh techniques such as
the selency right um that talks about uh
uh you know the importance of say words
features you know notes in the graph
right um uh it try to extract this
important structure and importantly for
graphs we might even have to exp uh uh
extract important scores for subgraphs
right so um this is definitely like one
approach that is inspired from like
linear regression you know another uh
kind of approach is called attribution
which means that you know this kind of
feature contributes to x% of our
prediction right this also like
definitely uh like a result of Dimension
reduction and linear regression uh
inspired from these kind of explainable
models and then finally there's also
Concepts and prototypes so it talks
about in general this class has certain
kind of characteristics you can see them
as like like a particular group under
like a branch of a decision tree so um
um um so those are you know methods that
also uh trying to bring some of those
traditionally very explainable models to
like the Deep learning context okay all
right so uh another uh um aspect is that
explainable AI can be different from
different domains but uh you know
underlying all these applications we
have a very similar principle so uh for
example in computer vision what was
explainable right so let's say we have
an image here um and we want to talk
about you know why is it being
classified as say like a cat with some
probability or dog with some probability
right and uh you know we can uh look at
it with respect to the doc logic so so
you know treat the vector on the right
as the prediction logic right after the
soft Max um so if we look at the cat
then it highlights the portion of the
cat at the bottom right so this was kind
of cency map that highlights importance
of each pixel right um so it the cat and
then you know you know if we switch it
to the doc uh logit then it's going to
tell tell us you know what was the uh
what was the part of the image that
helps the model decide that it's kind of
like a dog image right and then the dog
part was highlighted so this is an
example in com verion but we see the
pattern right so we want to extract like
a subset of the input that are
particularly important for the
prediction right that's uh that's what
we did in linear regression that's also
what we do in CV and as we will see it's
also the case for NLP and graphs as well
right let's say in the context of
natural language processing we have some
input right and and we're doing this
sentiment classification right we're
predicting whether the senten has a
positive or negative sentiment we run
through some kind of language model
right whatever um and the explanation is
going to highlight the portion of the
sentences that contribute to the
sentiment right like for example the uh
entertaining right a cool effects those
have like high importance values to the
prediction of being like positive
sentiment right on the other hand if you
look at the bottom row there's the
negative part right uh there's uh bad
and peeling off right so this these
words that have negative connotations
will get highlighted so again it's a
subset of the input that particularly
contributes to the prediction made by
the model all right um again same for
graph learning right this is what we're
going to talk about today um um again
the same principle right uh we're going
to extract a subset of the input such
that it contributes uh to a particular
uh prediction made by the model right
but in this case it's uh more
complicated because we not only have
like a subset of feature Dimensions
which we usually care about right let's
say in the uh similar to a subset of
pixels and stuff like that but there's
also this uh structure component right
we want to extract a subset of uh graphs
right the topological structure like a
subgraph such that it particularly
contributes to the model prediction okay
so we uh keep in mind we have the both
aspects to capture uh when we go through
the methods okay um right so um yeah so
why is this important right why do we
need to capture structure what do we
need capture feature at the same time
for uh G explainability um so typically
um um we have uh two kinds of U purposes
uh in order to explain both aspects
right so uh we have um we might
sometimes want the gns to or we want to
explain the ground truth phenomenon
let's say I have a molecule uh property
prediction task right I given a molecule
I predict whether uh it is toxic or not
right something like that so uh we want
to understand what makes a molecule
toxic right we don't don't don't just
want a model that magically outputs me
toxic versus non toxic but we want to
under like find the reasons why it is
toxic or not right um so that's like
trying to investigate the ground truth
phenomena is particularly uh important
in like any kind of science applications
right um but on the bottom side it's
about explaining model prediction right
let's say this is another scenario where
um uh you know we have a customer that
is applying for a loan in a bank right
uh and and we have you know a a bank
transaction Network we run a graph neur
net on top of it we predict whether uh
um you know the it is advisable to uh
approve the loan for the customer uh
right so it's again a binary
classification yes or no uh and in this
case it says no right uh so what we
understand want to understand in this
case is why does the model recommend No
loan for this person right is it because
it has a low credit history is it
because it has the loan amount is too
big you know some kind of reason right
we don't just want to deny a customer
because the model predicts no right we
want to give them reasons that they they
can help them be successful next time
right so this instead of like explaining
the gr truth we're more like explaining
model where where you can think of it as
almost like debugging the model right
see why does the model recommends no
long for this person right is it because
of this feature is it because the that
feature right is this a you know a fair
thing to do right let's say if uh the
model we discover through explainability
that the model is um um is recommending
No loan because of some uh you know
protected characteristics such as uh uh
gender you know race this kind of thing
that's definitely like a no right we
shouldn't be doing that and that's what
expendability can can help Okay and in
this case you know a gender you know
stuff like that can be like a uh feature
whereas uh you know uh transaction
Behavior can be like a subgraph so
that's exactly what we talked about when
we said you know a sub subgraph and a
feature uh both are important and uh for
explaining such a prediction
okay all right and um I also listed some
references in case people are interested
so there have been a lot of Works in
terms of explainable AI in general so
there are like a proxy based approach
shab is a very popular one used in
industry and Academia as well um uh
there's saliency or gradient based
methods such as gret cam um there's
attention mechanism right we talk about
graph attention models here and we get
those attention values and they they can
be quite useful when explaining model
prediction right we can look at which
one is the current node paying attention
to and um is that node you know that
kind of pattern important for the
prediction so um attention is definitely
like another important uh approach okay
and uh the final part of section one is
just going to be you know reasons why uh
you know explainability is an important
uh um topic right first of all it gives
us a sense of trust right uh we
understand you know what the Black Box
is doing we no longer treat that as
magic we are able to understand what are
the features that causes model to make
certain predictions um that's very
important for you know fairness and
debugging and many other reasons okay
and sometimes it also gives us a sense
of causality um it's not always the case
but a lot of times it gives us some kind
of causality right so like certain
feature or certain kind of input cause
CES you know a prediction to be like
that so we can you know depending on
whether the outcome is something we
desire we might want to fix it or we
might want to just utilize that kind of
inductive bias right to understand the
phenomenon better okay um it also has a
big implication in terms of
transferability right let's give you a
very simple example um so if um if I'm
uh let's say in in my data set I have a
lot of dogs right I want to classify
whether the image has a dog or not right
I have a lot dogs but every time a dog
appears there's also a person that
appears right so that's just a
particular characteristic of this data
set and uh uh you know we can use
expendability to say to see whether you
know the the reason of predicting a dog
is because there's a dog or there is a
person and it's just like there's a high
uhu uh correlation between person and
dog in this particular data set right so
understanding whether you know which one
is going to be the case is going to have
a big uh implication in terms of
transferability because you know if you
you have a a new data set that has dogs
but don't have uh don't have like any
person in it then of course your model
wouldn't be able to transfer right um
okay and and finally uh I talk about
fairness and and ethical decision making
right we want to talk uh think about uh
whether the explainability or
explanation made by the model is uh uh
something that's reasonable to do and if
it's not we should do something that
fixes it right but expendability let us
at least investigate this
phenomenon all right um so um yeah so uh
I will also talk about the settings here
um um there are many ways we can
formulate this problem of expandability
uhu and uh here is like different ways
that we can uh formulate the setting so
first of all we can explain by Target so
we can say um it is an explanation for a
particular instance versus an
explanation for the entire model or like
for a particular class of the B right
instance level means that I focus on one
particular data point right let's say
this image or this node in know graph
and say why is this node being predicted
as a uh you know no loan for for this
customer um and so we're only going to
explain for that instance right the
explanation is specific to that instance
whereas model level explanation would
mean uh you know what is the general
characteristic of uh a toxic molecule
right uh so you know it might gives us
some understanding of the functional
group of the molecule right some
interaction between atoms you know what
what in general toxic molecule looks
like so those are like more like model
level or class level uh explanation and
uh in particular we're going to focus on
in instance level because um I guess
it's the first step model level
explanations are out there right there
are some papers uh on it but uh it's
still a very active area of research um
and in fact I'm uh I I'm doing like an
ongoing work for model level explanation
on gns as
well okay and and settings can also be
classified in other ways right uh we can
also say expandability settings by
stages uh we can have expandability
being injected into this pipeline in at
different stages right we can inject it
uh before the model fitting right uh so
we can think of it as like being
inherent uh in the model right let's say
I have a model that is intrinsically
explainable or interpretable which means
that you know you can use attention or
something like that and once the model
is optimized we automatically have that
explanation right so that's uh often
called anti-hog and sometimes called uh
you know intrinsic uh interpretability
um and there's another type of
explainability which we are going to
focus on that is post hog explainability
so this means that I have a model that
is already trained right let's say it's
a pre-trained model or uh you know like
any kind of network we already where we
already fix the weights right it's
already well optimized and we want to
have an additional module that build on
top of it right we just bring in this
additional expendability module to
investigate why the model makes certain
prediction right so that's all Al often
called post hog explainability right the
disadvantage is of course you know you
have an additional module component you
have it's not like intrinsic to the
model so it's like requires
postprocessing and even like
optimization as we will see uh to
generate the explanation right that's
like more time consuming and so on but
the advantage is that it's kind of
agnostic to the model right we don't
require the model itself to be
interpretable right we don't require it
to have attention you know we don't
require it to have um you know say
some kind of linear components or
anything like that right any kind of
blackbox model we should be able to
apply post hog expendability right so
that's kind of difference in terms of
their
stages and another uh yes short question
so I'm assuming there's also learned
ways for the explainability model that
happens post hot right yeah so what is
stopping us from then going deep
learning on that too and then having a
model that explains the explanation of
the model that explains the explainer
the explainer of the model yeah yeah
yeah there are people actually do that
like in CV for example last year I I
remember there was a paper you know you
use a deep learning model to generate an
explanation in fact the Deep generative
model to generate the explanation that
explains you know
another deep image classification model
so there are definitely people uh who do
that and a lot of times those actually
give us a lot better performance um the
only thing that can be a little bit
worried is uh this kind of It kind of
applies like all the problems of like
learned classifier right so like we
might be worried that the model is not
robust right it's not predicting us like
the correct explanation it's not stable
right if I perur the pixels a little bit
it predicts completely different things
um different things as explanation so
like all these uh issues um but it's
definitely like a possible approach like
people always uh try to do that and and
like you mention this recursion right
like explaining something that is trying
to explain something else I haven't seen
people doing that but um yeah
I I I don't know if there is any use
case of such uh but I think people are
on the first level currently like trying
to just generate a good explanation for
a deep learning model not really
investigating what the explainer itself
is doing right so but you can imagine
that once we have a very good Universal
explainer that say as good as say a
large language model nowadays then we
can come up with you know ways
additionally to investigate what the
explainer is doing right um but that's a
definitely like a natural line of
thought um so yeah anyways good question
so um the Third Kind of uh setting
difference is that uh um applicability
right can uh can also specify the
setting which can be model specific that
means that the explainability method is
only going to be applied to a certain
class of models but we can also try to
be model agnostic which means that no
matter what uh the underlying model is
doing we always able to uh explain
something out of it right um or at least
model agnostic to some extent let's say
any kind of G GNN or any kind of uh uh
Transformers you know things like that
okay all right so I think I finished
everything about explainability and uh
problem study uhu let me know if there
is any question by the way it's like
feel free to raise your hand uh if
there's any question um but I I'll give
you guys uh an example of what we have
done on uh GNN explainer uh which is
very the first and very commonly used
GNN explainability methods uh that is
still quite popular uh to nowadays um
and and I'll go on to like how we
evaluate this thing okay um so I think
we talk about this example already right
we have some kind of transaction
networks in the financial markets and it
can be uh formulated as a graph where we
have uh nodes connected through
transactions right and we can use a
graph new network to predict you know
whether each user is trustworthy or
risky client and then we can decide you
know whether we want to give a loan to
the person or not right um and there are
a lot more applications I'm sure you
guys are already exposed to them U after
taking this class right for example in
the recommended system you know people
gets recommended with different items
you can see it as a kind of a uh
predicting what the person might buy in
future right it can also be a molecule
classification I think in the past few
lectures might have talked about
molecule generation or molecule property
prediction right um predicts the
property of the molecule as a whole
graph um and and I have the fraudulent
the financial Network example here so in
those cases we are explaining different
kind of targets right so in the first
one we're explaining link prediction
right we're explaining what is uh what
is connecting each other right what what
will be the future connection um in the
second case we're explaining graph
classification because we are having uh
one label for entire molecule right as a
graph and um in a third case it's going
to be a node classification right uh
every node represents a user and we want
to see investigate why the user is say
classified as fraudulent or not
trustworthy risky and all that all right
um so yeah different targets so let's
consider all of these right um so um as
I said this uh this pipeline is going to
be a post hog framework which means that
uh um um this is going to be an extra
module that we bring in um and um uh try
to explain the GNN that we have already
trained right it's the post talk setting
so how it works is going to be like at
training time we optimize the GNN on the
training graph as usual right we train
let's say a GNN for the molecule right
and then we save the training model so
that model is kind of fixed already uh
and at test time we are explaining a
prediction made by the GNN right so U uh
let's say GNN make prediction that the
molecule is toxic U now say even on an
unseen instance right we have never seen
this instance before uh have never seen
this molecule before and want to
understand what makes this molecule
toxic right and U and that is where we
bring the explainability module right as
the uh student just said it can be you
know a deep module it can be a very
shallow module you know um and in fact
GNN explainer is sort of like a shallow
module I would say so it's not something
like a deep model that is optimizing for
explanation uh but like a lot of deep
model uh based explanations are
available nowadays as
well um okay so um yeah so look that
these are these are the overall goals
right we want to explain different kinds
of test right no classification graph
classification whatever uh we also want
uh uh the explanation to be post Haw
which means it is model agnostic right
we want to be able to apply it to any
kind of message passy networks um and we
also want the predictions um to uh like
we also want to take into account that
some of the predictions are based on a
complex combination of nodes edges
between them motive subgraphs right um
like not just the feature information
but also the complex structure
information and how that contri rutes to
model prediction right and um one thing
to note is that that different from say
computer vision gradient is typically
less reliable on real world graphs uh
because a lot of times you know there is
this discrete nature of having an edge
versus not having an edge right it's
kind of 01 scenario and uh gradients are
often uh behaving less well compared to
like continuous uh things where uh for
example like pixel you can have values
between say 0 to 25 255 or something
like that's more more continuous right
so uh in those cases uh selency or
gradient uh which was a common method in
CV typically works less well all right
um so uh we're looking at a model
agnostic uh explanation right so um the
target is basically be able to explain
any kind of message passing Network so
anything that you know uses this kind of
message passing uh uh uh structure right
and and we want to discover you know
what has what is important so by the way
this you know can has the potential to
apply to Transformer and anything like
that as well so any anytime you have
those kind of message passing structure
um and and there are two kinds of
explanations we want to extract one is
the structural explanation and one is
the feuture explanation so feature
explanation should be very easy to
understand right I crossed out some of
the feature Dimensions uh so this
basically means that you know some of
the features are less important some of
features are more important so want to
kind of understand uh what has
contributed to the model prediction
uh you know is it uh you know uh this
node feature or that node feature right
something like that um and at the same
time we also want to uh extract the
structural explanation which is about uh
uh you know the topology of the graph so
let's say the green part of this graph
are the edges that contribute to a
prediction right we can uh from the
green part of the topology we can
perhaps you know understand what has uh
going what has been going on why is this
structure corresponding to like toxic
molecule let's say so maybe in the
transaction Network example this uh
structural explanation can be some like
fraudulent uh uh uh transaction patterns
right um let's say in a molecule it can
be some kind of substructure of the
molecule that forms a important
functional group for being like toxic or
like whatever um property uh that you
are predicting right and and the goal is
to extract all of these
simultaneously okay so let's go into the
algorithm a little bit uh and before
that uh let's just Define some simple
symbols which uh I'm sure you all should
be quite familiar at this point right we
have the input computation graph um so
note that I'm using this term like
computation graph which means it can be
different from the original you know
graph structure right so this is the
graph where we used to do message
passing right and message passing edges
can be you know multihop message passing
or I don't know sampled message passing
you know uh so it it might not be the
original graph okay um so we denoted as
g under um uh um subscript C right uh
for computation graph of a particular
node B okay and adjacency Matrix uh of
GC we denote it as AC right um it's just
the uh 01 kind of representation right
um and we can also consider weighted
edges in which case you know this will U
can be weighted right um and no features
uh we use XC right these are all like so
whenever there's a subscript C this
means the original computation graph or
the original data that we use as input
right um so these are like the set of
all the features that belong to this
competition graph
um okay and and we also have our GN
model right remember this is post hog
explanation which means the model is
being fixed uh before uh we try to
explain it right we already have a model
that is uh well trained okay so we call
this model fee uh and and and basically
uh without loss of generality I'm
assuming let's say classification but uh
regression is going to be the very
similar case you just switch the law
right but let's say it's a
classification right so um we use P of V
which is the model denotes the
prediction probability right let's say
it's a multiclass uh classification
right it's going to be like a a softmax
kind of distribution right so like a
discrete distribution that sums to one
so we call that P of v um and a note
that we wrote it as like the Y which is
the prediction uh condition on you know
the computation graph because uh you
know for GNN computation graph is all we
need in order to Output this prediction
uh why right so that's all like that's
all the information the model has so the
explanation has to be like a subset of
uh as you can imagine subset of AC and
XC all right um and uh what GNN expander
outputs is a subset right so as s is
kind of a subset of AC as you can sort
of see it as like a adjacency matrix for
a subgraph of GC by the original graph
okay um and similarly XS is uh uh kind
of a subset of the feature Dimensions um
so this is only specific to features
that are uh included in the nodes in the
as right in the subgraph uh and then
mask by some feature so you can see on
the visualization on the right right
let's say this entire thing is the GC
the computation graph and then I'm
highlighting some of these green notes
so these are the noes that are part of
the GS right or part of the as right
those nodes are in the explained
subgraph right and then on top of that
for each of these nodes in the for each
of the green nodes we cross out some of
the dimensions right so there are some
important Dimensions being kept for
nodes that are in the green part of the
uh subgraph right so that's all we have
in the explanation so the important
features versus uh and the important uh
subgraph information okay um so that way
we can capture both the substructure and
the important feature uh feature
Dimensions okay um so uh we use this
Mass like as a feature Mass kind of that
mass out all the features that are not
important to the prediction okay all
right so the objective for expandability
uh as we frame in this paper is going to
be mutual information which is a very
commonly used objective in many other
scenarios as well whenever we want to
talk about expandability or correlation
R to understand uh how how features are
related feature predictions are related
right so uh here we are kind of uh try
to maximize the mutual information
between the output feature as well as
the input subground right so the
subgraph of the computation graph uh you
know you can imagine that uh an
important subgraph or like an important
subset features for this prediction must
be highly correlated or must have a high
Mutual information with the prediction
uh uh that is called why right um and um
this basically like very basic
information Theory stuff right so uh
relation to entropy with Mion
information is M information of XY is
the um uh entropy of x minus conditional
entropy of x on y but it can also be
written the other way around like
entropy of Y minus h y given X um and
and it's symmetric so um um by
definition um so mutual information of
XY is basically the same as Y and X okay
um and and our objective is going to be
uh maximizing uh between the uh Mutual
information of label uh between the
label and the expanation so the label
here is the Y the explanation is a uh
the subg graph right and subg graph and
subset features okay which U by
expanding the previous equation you will
get this um but something to not is that
the Hy is already fixed because the
model is uh is already trained right we
finished remember it's the post hog set
right so the model is already trained so
Hy is fixed and um the thing that we
really want to maximize is essentially
the second part of the term right so the
conditional entropy of Hy given the
subgraph and the subset of features
which are termed as as and U Xs
um doesn't make sense uh any question so
far in terms of like objectives and
settings okay hopefully people
understand all right um here should be
uh pretty clear so so want to uh yes
somehow like getting flashback from like
statistical mechanics you have to assume
something about independence in order to
have that
relationship for
the I think it's true for any like
there's no requirement for X and Y being
independent or anything um it's just a
symmetric function like if you write out
the mutual information formula which I
forgot to write here I might have I
might have to actually write write on
slides U you can see it's imp uh it's
kind of flippable um yeah it's basically
like a joint divided by condition or
something but that's uh uh that doesn't
assume any Independence we do have a lot
of assumptions here as you will see but
not not now um all right here's the
assumptions or the approximations that
we're doing all right so uh yeah as as
we said by relational entropy like what
we care is actually the second term
because the first term Hy is pretty much
fixed given the model is already trained
right um uh so maximizing theal
information is essentially minimizing
the conditional entropy of uh y given
this uh this as and Fs right just as a
sorry XS uh just as a reminder as is the
adjacency for the subgraph that is
important for the pred ition and again
XS is the subset of features that are
important for the prediction right so we
I try to identify these subs and this is
what we put it here right uh so the max
is over all possible as's which is like
all possible subgraphs of the original
computation graph okay um and um um yeah
I guess I uh we can put the f as well
right so so this part is just for like
extracting the structural explanation so
I put as but you can also put the F so
the feature Mass there as well for
optimizing for all possible feature
subsets okay um one issue with this is
that this is very computationally
expensive um minimizing this conditional
entropy across all possible subgraphs is
exponential right you can imagine there
are exponentially many possible
subgraphs of a given computation graph
um and and what we uh thought can be a
good approximation is that we treat this
explanation as a plausible explanation
and a distribution of PL explanation
right and and which we kind of basically
replace it uh with the expectation of
that distribution so that's just a way
to justify why we are doing this
relaxation right so there are some
benefits of doing that right first of
all um we can capture multiple possible
explanations you can imagine that
sometimes uh you know when predicting
something uh a lot of explanations can
can be reasonable right we can say like
uh uh the person is classified as being
uh uh risky because it has these kind of
features and and interaction patterns at
this point in time and it might also be
because it has this kind of interaction
patterns at some other time right with
some other organizations so we can treat
it as like a multiple possible
explanations and and uh treat it as a
distribution right and and this will
also turn us uh turn uh into like a
continuous optimization rather than
discreet right which incurs exponential
around time uh this is just by doing
like taking expectation of the uh of the
Matrix and this is what we're doing um
uh like what I mean by taking the
expectation so uh that's uh say uh we
Define this a distribution of all
possible you know explanations as this
curly a right so um instead of uh
instead of minimizing this conditional
entropy uh we now just minimizing the
expectation of the conditional entropy
with this U um across all the all the
possible explanations okay um
and and this is the step of
approximation that we're doing you
notice that we basically bring in this
expectation inside uh that is true for a
convex function that is not true in
general so um so this is kind of like
approximation right um um um but like in
practice we observe it it kind of works
okay and it also makes us much faster in
terms of round time so that's why uh
we're doing this right but uh if you
look at the second equation right what
what this expectation is um um
it's basically like saying I have a
multiple of these adjacency Matrix I
take the average of all these adjacency
Matrix that's our kind of expectation
right of all possible explanations of as
okay and and we can treat this as a a
kind of a continuous masking of the
original adjacency right so we have the
original AC this is the adjacency for
the computation graph and we just
basically do an element wise multiply on
a mask right and the mask is something
that is between zero and one which means
that um you you know if we completely
mask out something it's going to have
Zero Entry if we have uh if the mass is
one right it uh doesn't mask anything it
will be one but there's going to be
something in between right a lot of
values between zero and one which makes
it continuous rather than a discrete
optimization right and if it's
continuous we have gradients and
everything now we can uh we can do
gradient descent right life is good um
so if the mass is close to one that
means the intuition is that we keep the
edge because this Edge is important
right if the mass is zero we kind of
remove it because this Edge has nothing
uh is it's not important for the
prediction okay so um so let's say um we
have this Mass to be more concrete um
this Mass can be like kind of the values
that we learn so these are the uh you
know entries that we will optimize with
gradient descent as like this post hog
explainer right so everything in this
mass is learnable and after we learn the
parameters uh it will pass through the
sigmoid right so the sigmoid basically a
squash that ensures that your value is
between zero and one okay um and then we
kind of element wise multiply that with
adjy right as as shown here um so we
basically replace that expectation with
the uh adjacency of the original
computation graph doing the element wise
multiplication with this 0 to one mask
um is that clear any questions so far
awesome okay um yeah so now we have this
right remember we replace this
expectation with uh with AC element wise
uh uh mask okay and and this is our
objective now and this is track right
after doing this approximation so this
uh remember this P5 is basically the
prediction probability distribution by
GNN uh with this uh pre-trained
parameters data right we already trained
this GNN so this uh distribution is uh
can be easily computed by doing a
forward propagation of the model okay um
and we are minimizing over op possible
M's right remember that we replace that
as with this AC element wise M and AC is
fixed so all we need to do is to
optimize for all possible M and M is
continuous right remember it's a after
sigmoid it's like a number between zero
and one uh real number okay so as an
interpretation it can be something like
like that right so imagine that before
training this is our AC right the
original computation graph uh adjacency
Matrix right and after multiplying by
The Mask which we trained you know some
of the entries become lighter in this
heat map because the values drop closer
to zero right and some of the values
kept as like a higher value as one right
so we have like a you know treat this as
sort of like a soft subgraph of AC right
and that is kind of potential
explanation right so after that we can
just do a thresholding right to get rid
of all these uh know lighter edges the
edges that have been masked out right
and and you know translate translating
it to the graph domain it's going to be
like the before training we have a large
graph and after training because some of
the edges are mased out we have a
smaller graph right we can ensure it's
connected by some other ways like
regularization or like when we do
thresholding we uh encourage
connectedness if that's something uh
that people needs like having an
connected explanation okay so um yeah
that's the thing um all right and and so
that is basically the structural
explanation right so we have the um
extracted the subgraph out of the
original graph that is particularly
important for some prediction okay we
did what we promised and uh this is the
feature part right uh and that's
basically almost the same as the uh as
the subgraph part except uh uh we are
selecting a set of feature subdimensions
rather than uh subgraphs so in essence
it's like easier right uh so um but we
do basically the same thing right we
have a mask that is learnable that is uh
applied on each of these feature
Dimensions um and uh uh you know if it
goes to zero that means the feature is
not important if it's uh one that means
the feature is important right um and
and that way we kind of select the
subset of features that uh uh dominates
the prediction as well all right so
there's a there's a slight issue that uh
you know zero values can be important
that's not like uh that's kind of
different from graphs right U like all
the structural explanation because uh
you know the fact that uh something is
not present can be a good signal for
predicting something right like having a
zero in particular Dimension doesn't
mean that this Dimension is not
important it just means that there's a
negative signal on that Dimension okay
so um in this case we can also do uh
like a uh uh this uh feature importance
measurements by changing uh how we treat
things as being important right we can
we can treat uh uh we can see like how
much it deviates from basically a
expandability baseline right uh so this
is a common concept have called Baseline
common Concept in explainability and
it's applied in like say integrated
gradients and Shar and everything um so
uh I Define Baseline here the Baseline
is basically treated as a null model of
a feature right so like uh or like a
prior of the feature so if you don't
know anything just from observing the
data set you don't know anything about
an instance what's the expected value of
the uh uh of this uh feature Dimension
right so you can imagine it as like on
average or just treating as the mean of
the marginal distribution right on
average uh what is the value of that so
we can treat that as the nor model right
by default it is that and zero is being
negative of that so we can U now have
like a reparameterization so um you know
if the mass is one that means zero is
important if mass is zero then we move
the mean uh sorry we move uh the the
value from zero to the marginal
distribution right that's just
uninformative prior of the feature so
there's uh this small tweak and if you
want to know more uh you can refer to
the paper for for more detail but um
other than that most of the things are
similar yes how you handle redundancy in
the features right like it might be that
if you remove if you have a set of five
features and they redundant you remove
any one of them or three of them you
don't lose any explainability but if
you're all of them you do lose a lot
exactly so uh are you asking about uh
how we measure the effectiveness of
expendability in terms of removing
redundancy yeah I guess I'm asking how
you discover
which like the potentially a large set
is important or you need some subset of
a large set yeah and how you assign
relative importance to the numbers of it
yeah so we call that conciseness or
complexity of explanation that's
definitely like very important
evaluation mat we'll talk about later
but we essentially also want to
encourage conciseness actually I will
show that like right now I think so uh
yes right now uh uh so you look at the
objective we have two additional terms
on the right right so um basically it
controls the size of the explanation
right we have the mask kind of size and
then the feature size right we basically
don't want the mass to be all once right
if uh it's all once then of course you
recover the original prediction you're
very accurate but then there's it
defeats the purpose of explaining
because you're not masking out any of
these redundant features right so that's
why we add this regularization term to
enforce the mask to be as concise as
possible right we want the explanations
to say like having say no more than 10
edges or something like that so all of
these can be like uh done through you
know L Ranch multiplier you know
regularization this kind of issue to uh
to ensure that your the output is uh is
not redundant uh does that answer your
question I think so yeah can you get
with using this
procedure you get just the single most
concise
explanation uh so there's always going
to be a trade-off right so like the more
concise is it is the less likely it's
going to recover the original prediction
you might have some inaccuracy at the
end right but the hope is uh you don't
remove something that's too critical so
that's always going to be the trade-off
and you can always plot the the uh I
guess conciseness versus the the
prediction uh you know faithfulness of
the explanation and then you know pick
something that is on the sweet spot for
you right it can be application specific
for example in molecules let's say I
have like 30 atoms in a molecule the
predic the the explanations we typically
regard them as functional groups or
important substructure and typically you
know these kind of function groups has
like five nodes or something right that
might be a prior we want to get we want
the explanation to be like no more than
say 10 nodes um whereas in let's say a
recommended system maybe I'm more
interested in looking at the interaction
patterns and some of these patterns are
non-trivial right it can be like
multiple people interacting with the
same uh same item or it can be the other
way around it can be like a cycle of
people connecting with each each other
uh or it can be a fully connected click
so this kind of structure typically
requires more edges and more nodes uh so
we can increase the budget to make the
explanation larger so that's kind of
application dependent all right thank
you um yeah so uh uh one thing that I
also want to highlight here is that the
optimization is performed when
explaining every instance so remember
that we talk about the instance
explanation and the model level
explanation this is the instance level
explanation want to explain what happens
to a instance right which means that uh
the mass is specific to that instance as
well so we have a separate mass for
every instance uh and how do we that get
a mass we do this optimization so
luckily it's not that expensive after
all this optimization right um or all
this simplification um you know you
typically run it for like uh 50
iterations and it's already converged so
um and then the subgraph the competition
graph is also not likely to be big so
it's not like a big cost but then it's
still a sizable cost and that's actually
a concern right right so going back to
one of the questions that this one of
the students has asked right can we use
a deep model to predict the explanation
so that's actually an advantage of using
that right so instead of uh doing this
kind of shadow model where we have to do
optimizations for every node uh when we
explaining that Noe uh we just build a
deep model that splits out all the
explanations given any instance right
there are already people who did that um
it's called PG explainer right um um um
and and that kind of get rid of get rid
of this optimization need um at every
instance right but other than that most
of the other methods like most of the
pipeline still applies it's just the uh
you know how uh this parameterization of
M whether we treat M as a learnable
parameter as we we're doing now in gen
and explainer or we treat M as an model
output of a certain explainable uh
explainability method right using like a
deep neuron Network that's the only
difference everything else still applies
okay all right right um so uh finally
want to just talk a little bit about uh
the explainability uh uh applicability
right applying to different kind of
tests and as we said in node
classification uh uh is basically the
computation graph is going to be the
neighborhood of the node that we are
going to make predictions on right so we
optimize the mass just on the Node
neighborhood itself in a link prediction
um you know imagine what are the
structure uh uh uh substructures that
can potentially affect the link is going
to be the uh neighborhood of uh one node
Union the neighborhood of the other node
right because you're predicting that
link so you know naturally you can take
the union of these two neighborhood and
treat that as your GC everything else
still applies um in the case of graph
classification um it's basically on the
entire graph right you basically input
the entire graph as your GC um and then
you optimize the same thing it's the
same method okay um um but for graph
classification usually the graph itself
is not too big so it's still uh
computationally feasible
and again this uh can be adapted to any
kind of message passing uh architecture
as as long as there is message passing
right so we assume in Assumption we
assume there's a message passing in the
computation graph and that's all we
assume right so we can apply this post
Haw method to you know Gat uh G graph
sequence you know graph networks graph
stage like any U GNN methods that we
talk about um uh in in this course right
um so yeah um any questions so far
okay cool if not I I'll switch gradually
switch to evaluation right uh so we can
talk about you know how we compare with
some alternative methods but uh so
before I do that I just give a quick
overview of what are some uh baselines
that you can always consider when trying
to explain the model right uh one very
simple approach is called saliency or
the gradient right um um it's just like
a quick analogy from the linear
regression example that I just showed
before right before we have this slope
that indicates importance now we have a
gradient of a very complex surface right
nevertheless gradient still a local
approximation of the slope right so you
can imagine that if U you know if one of
the particular input feature has a high
gradient it's going to affect the
prediction a lot right if that means if
I change the input a little bit the
output prediction the probability will
change a lot right whereas um you know a
flat won't give you that much so we can
still have this uh gradient information
but uh please not that the gradient is
with respect to the uh input not the
weight right so in the typical GNN
optimization we take the gradient of the
weights but now we'll take the gradient
of the input right the input can be the
adjacency edges or it can be the feature
Dimensions right so these are the the
signals we can use to threshold right to
understand which edges are important
because they have High
gradients um another alternative
approach is obviously through attention
um I think we covered uh GN Transformers
in this C right um so like um it's like
all of these architectures have uh
attention Wass that are between notes
right for example uh you know uh in a
recommended system an item gets
recommended to a user there's an
attention value and depending on that
attention value we can just directly
threshold out uh notes that are uh not
important but there are some issue with
that right it typically results in like
disconnected uh explanations and it also
uh it's not as ideal as you would think
because you know there's multi head and
there's like attention across all the
layer it's just um not as ideal as you
would think but it's definitely like one
way um so let's say I want to compare
all these methods and how how would we
compare um so we uh so in the case of uh
when Ground truths available we can of
course like compare with the ground
truth right and that's what we did in
this original paper right we designed
this synthetic Tas such that we actually
have some idea about the ground truth
right so this is a particular task uh
that basically ask is a node part of a
given Motif let's say the motif is a is
a house structure right on the left you
see the green five node house right if
the motive if if the node is part of
this motive I give it as label one
otherwise I give it as label zero right
so a very simple uh structure based
prediction task um and and you can
imagine that in those case how do I
explain a note that is of a you know
part of the given motive of course the
motive itself right like if the
explanation can highlight this house
then I'm good right um then the
explanation you know recovers what is
needed for the prediction and same thing
goes for let's say a six cycle Motif or
like a grid kind of motif right so in
the data set we attach uh these kind of
motifs randomly to this big graph let's
say a gra any kind of graph generator
like a bar graphs um or a tree graph or
anything like that and we just randomly
attach a bunch of these and highlight
these notes as particular label one and
then we try to explain those noes that
belong to those motives okay um and then
we can also do it for other data sets
like in you know molecules and and uh
social network recommended system and
all these um the only caveat is that uh
these are not uh um we don't have ground
Truth for those okay um so I mentioned
that for the synthetic data set we
already have the ground truth right like
the house you know the grid and so on so
we can directly see like what's how
accurate is the EXP expendability method
in recovering that particular motive
right and because we know exactly what
the gr truth is we can compute the
accuracy for for that or Au whatever
metric you prefer right and and we can
you know compare our method with you
know attention and gradient based
methods um for these kind of data sets
right uh so here's some kind of
visualization and um you know as you
would expect having a high score means
that you kind of recover that motive so
notice that I um manually set like a
higher explanation threshold uh because
uh you know sometimes the model is not
exactly accurate so you know the house
might not be the the top five um uh
notes but if I say like I pick top 10
then most likely this top five is going
to appear right and then if we look at
multiple of these instances then of
course we can understand you know maybe
house is basically the reason for uh for
this uh particular prediction of class
one right something like that so um you
can imag uh you can see that it roughly
aligns with the ground Truth uh pretty
well for the synthetic data sets as
well okay so I will talk about more
challenging settings of evaluating the
St right uh especially in cases where
the ground shs are not available so
we've also uh did this paper on uh
learning on graphs conference last year
on uh explainability taxonomy and
evaluation so we particularly study uh
issu or like scenarios where these kind
of ground TRS are not available and can
we have a good systematic way of
evaluating that okay so um this is recap
this is all we did in the GNN explainer
and most of the explainability methods
right we have some input graph we have
this kind of mass generation thing it
can be a deep model it can be directly
optimized whatever right it picks out
identifies important feature dimensions
and adjacency right and then you know
you get a feature mask you get a graph
mask and then these are the the
predictions right or the explanations
for the model okay and uh this is where
we are so G explainer similar to most
many many papers that uh kind of follow
uh follow this line of direction is you
know part of this perb based approaches
but as you can see there like
expandability is a very big landscape
right we have those gradient based uh uh
decomposition based you know surrogate
models and all these things and one note
is that you know the thing on the right
uh the pink one is the model level
explanation uh there's currently like
maybe one or two methods on that for
like uh uh explaining GNN predictions at
the model level so as I said it's
definitely like a major kind of area of
research where people where it's still
quite challenging
okay all right so um to evaluate all
these methods right to understand which
method is going to be used or more
effective uh which uh we want to uh
build this framework that uh can make
this kind of comparison right and we
want to stress that this kind of
evaluations is typically
multi-dimensional and uh some of the
students that uh have asked questions
you know brought up some aspects of it
right uh first uh we want to um
understand you know whether the goal is
to model the phen to explain the
underlying scientific phenomenon or
explaining why the model is making
certain prediction right so that's a
major distinction there's also masking
strategy difference whether you want a
soft mask versus like a hard thresholded
mask that will also affect evaluation uh
ranking of different methods um and I'll
talk about type right the necessity and
the uh sufficiency of the uh of the
explanation right so all these are being
explained in the
paper Okay so let's start with the uh
goal so as I said it is
multi-dimensional keep in mind like we
have multiple aspects it's not like a
single metric dominates everything it's
not like accuracy in a in in machinary
models uh um so phenomenal explanation
as I said it explain the underlying
reason whereas model explanation U makes
a explain why model makes a particular
prediction and we will have different uh
metric which we call Fidelity here to
measure the performance in both cases
right um so uh here is the U here is the
Highlight so uh yeah so this is the
formula for Fidelity and again you
already see that it's not a
onedimensional thing right you already
see two Dimension we have a metc called
Fidelity plus metric of fality minus
right um um so uh so here we classify as
go right go one is explain the
phenomenon the other explain what the
models learn so let's say we take the
phenomenon part right so the the left
part of the equation so Fidelity plus um
uh and minus kind of matches two
different aspects of uh necessity and
sufficiency of the explanation U so um I
guess to explain it a little bit so the
Y's here uh without the hat is the
ground truth right I highlighted that
and the blue part which has the white
hat right these are the model prediction
right and note that the model prediction
has a superscript there called GC uh uh
Slash uh s right so um GC is the
computation graph I hope you still
remember the notation and then s is the
let's say the subset of the features and
the the sub substructure that are being
extracted by the expendability so you
can imagine this uh as been saying like
what is the model prediction if I remove
that explanation from the original graph
right um same thing goes for like other
stuff okay so um so here is the uh so
these metrics are actually being pro
proposed in one of the other papers
called uh taxonomy uh GNN explaination
taxonomy paper right so um but we add
like additional insights on it so
Fidelity plus u so from the equation
here you can directly interpret Fidel
plus means that we basically remove that
important substructure right from the
original graph right you say it is
important I remove it see how you do
right so if it is really important uh
you better show like removing of that
gives you very bad performance right
that means you know that's that thing is
essential right or necessary let's say
right um so on the other hand Fidelity
minus um is um you know on the on the
green part right notice that we are only
keeping the important part so you say
this is important I remove everything
else I only keep that and see how you
perform right uh if this is thing is
really important you better show me that
the final performance or final model
prediction is not too much different
from the original prediction as if you
didn't remove anything right so you only
keep the important part it should give
you similar performance okay so these
are kind of the intuition of the metrics
and and actually the same thing goes go
for the uh the other part of the goal
except that you know we basically rep uh
uh replace the first part of the
indicator function with u just one
because in know ground truth you know if
I only care about ground truth um I just
make it like one or zero right depending
on what the ground truth actually is uh
so that's that's just the the only
difference okay uh but here for the
phenomenon we still keep the original
prediction because uh we care about
Model Behavior so we want to keep the
information about the original
prediction confidence here in the metric
as well
okay all right so um after talking about
this I want to also stress that uh the
explanation like I just talk about
sufficiency and necessity right so you
can imagine that f plus is necessity
right removing of that is bad right and
F minus is sufficiency right you having
that is already good enough okay um but
that's just one aspects of explanation
quality and typically people also
consider the other two aspects which is
explainability stability right how
stable is your explanation you better
like have a consistent explanation of
the same thing of the same model uh no
matter what your seed is and that's
actually a problem with the you know
deep model right if the Deep model is
going to make such prediction of small
pration can sometimes cause the
explanation to be very different and and
we don't like that so it's uh definitely
another evaluation that we should be
doing okay and the last uh uh is again
related to one of the other question
about explanation complexity uh we want
to make sure that model captures you
know all these good characteristics with
very concise explanation right imagine
that we have a model that you know get
very good Fidelity metrics but only if I
keep 50% of the addes that's pretty bad
right like if if my neighborhood has a
th edges does that mean the explanation
is like 500 edges that's pretty bad
right we want the explanation to be
concise and that's application dependent
but uh in any case we should have this
complexity being measured and evaluated
especially like a as a trade-off with
say the Fidelity metric that I proposed
uh just now okay so I talk about the
sufficiency and necessity of the uh
Fidelity metric and we can also like
combine them like similar to how we
combine precision and recall you know
any of these kind of necessity
sufficiency tradeoff as like a single
metric right so uh the uh measurement is
also actually pretty easy right just uh
you know do a harmonic mean of the
Fidelity and plus and Fidelity minus
with some of the weights right the most
common way to see it is like if I don't
have a prior just put the weights as one
right that's the typical harmonic mean
or that's how we compute U um you know
harmonic mean um but if I care about
sufficiency more or if I care about
necessity of the explanation more then
uh you know I can weit them accordingly
uh depending on my application needs
okay um so this is a bit more uh
explanation on uh how this works right
so imagine that we have this tradeoff
right we have the Fidelity plus um so it
is one minus Fidelity minus because you
know Fidelity uh zero zero is actually
pretty good right it means zero
difference between the the explan uh the
model output if it uses the explain
subgraph versus the original graph right
so we use minus y minus Fidelity minus
and then the X AIS is the Fidelity plus
so it treat this as kind of like a
Precision recall uh kind of thing right
so um so on the so we can draw this
curve of character ation uh score and
and on the top right it's going to be
one right um and if you go towards the
top part of the triangle it's going to
mean that the model is tend to be more
sufficient right it can tend to have
very good metric in terms of fidelity
minus whereas if it falls to the lower
triangle it means that it's kind of more
like a sufficient uh sorry necessary
explanation means that you know removing
this things is going to be bad but it's
not like these things alone would give
you good Pro uh prediction right so um
so have this kind of intuition um uh and
then again you know uh characterization
is basically like a um combination of
these two metrics okay all right so
let's look at some performance right so
given uh these metrics we can now
measure them against all the proposed
explanation methods right so uh here we
have on the right we have a bunch of
methods essay is saliency you know
occlusion integrated gradients page rank
gra cam genine explainer PGM explainer a
bunch of others right so like bunch of
genn explainability methods and and you
know we can EV now evaluate them see
like which ones uh are good in terms of
fidelity measuring like we can I
highlighted you know two circles there
are group of methods that are more on
the upper triangle right that are more
sufficient right I identifies the
component that actually gives us good
prediction and then there Al you know
this group red group of methods that are
tend to be more necessary so these are
the edges that are essential remove
moving them will give us bad prediction
but it doesn't capture the entire
picture of the explanation so you know
we can see these trade-offs of these
methods very well okay so another um uh
thing I want to mention is that the
conclusion of the uh comparability of
different uh uh uh explainability
methods can be very different depending
on data sets and tasks uh this is a data
set on eBay right a e-commerce graph
where we want to say like do anomaly
detection or uh recommend a system kind
of task and U in this case the uh
conclusion is very different right so
you can see this is very different from
the previous one uh I I won't go into
detail but you will see like the
rankings are quite different uh and
notably you know GN exper does pretty
well in this like large scale data set
um and it shows that you know it's not
just necessary but it's also giving us
like very good sufficient uh
explanations uh as well right so sorry
the other way WR it it's not just
sufficient but it also gives us
necessary explanation so I really
identify the the key aspects in The
Social Network um so um yeah like um so
what I want to say is there's no like a
very fixed uh uh conclusion yet for all
the expain methods and uh it will be
advised if you you know consider all
these different aspects uh when
evaluating you know how good a method is
in in your task
okay um so towards the end of the
lecture I want to uh give like maybe uh
two additional slides on other types of
explanations that people care about and
we are doing active research on uh so
these are the explanations uh uh that
are not fully developed yet but it's a
very active area if research in case
people are interested uh one type of uh
explanation is counterfactual
explanation so this doesn't care about
uh you know what makes the prediction
this way but it cares about what if
scenario like what if I make some
changes will it become another class
right what should I take to make this
input uh becoming uh to to make the
model predict the input as some other
class right so that's the contactual
setting uh there's some papers on it in
fact we have a paper in subm as well um
so it's useful in understanding the
distinction between classes you can
imagine it to trying to understand what
the decision boundary between different
classes how do I cross that decision
boundary basically um by adjusting the
input um so in realistic example you you
know can be like uh IND
um you know in a company people or
managers want to know you know what does
it take to convert the user from you
know being the predicted as an inactive
or turn kind of class to an active U
premium uh like premium user kind of uh
class right so that kind of gives people
insight about how to retain user better
how to uh uh uh basically um change some
of the input features that they can
control to attract the users more right
that's just one example there are a lot
of examp examples usage of contactual
explanations um and another one I have
stressed uh a lot uh in the lecture is
model level explanation that's very
important also so we don't want to care
about the uh one particular instance but
want to extract insights from all
instances of a certain class or like all
instances that are predicted to be a
certain class by the model right so it
basically means a common characteristics
or like some high level insights that
are not specific to individual classes
we can now sort of get through like
trying a lot of instance level
explanations and manually conclude
what's the conclusion is but like having
a systematic way of doing that is
actually not very easy like for example
this method uses an uh called xgn uses
an RL based approach uh to like add um
noes and addes such that it uh you know
achieves a high score for um all the
instances in the class right through uh
just through like policy uh gradient uh
so that's um like an example but again
it's not very easy method and and it's
also not very stable so people are still
doing research on that as well all right
okay I think that's mostly uh uh what I
want to cover for the lecture so I want
to conclude here so we talk about uh
expandability and I want to say like
it's a very essential area in
trustworthy GNN um like all these
aspects are related in my opinion like
explainability has a lot to do with
robustness because you know being able
to explain a robust model is will give
you good stuff right and but explain
something that's not robust we give you
Sero examples that's pretty bad and
expendability I already mentioned how
it's related to fairness right privacy
you know we don't want to use protected
characteristics we want to use
explanations to ensure that people's
privacy is protected uh you know it's
it's like all related all the all the
trustworthy aspects um and I we talk
about GNN explainer which is a
prediction uh sorry pration based
approach um the key inside is that we
want to optimize this mask uh in order
to achieve High Mutual information
between the prediction and the subset of
the substructure and the features that
are important for the prediction okay
and we also talk about explanation
evaluation which can be a challenging
thing to do compared to normal machine
learning evaluation because it is
multi-dimensional in nature we talk
about Fidelity complexity stability you
know all these uh different metrics and
uh you know sufficiency and necessity of
the explanations are something we have
to consider depending on the actual uh
application uh that we want to EXP
explain for um and then you know again
there are contactual M level
explanations that are worth additional
research um okay I think that's uh
everything I want to cover so we have
one minute so is there any like question
or
something uh can be related to Castle
can be like more high level doesn't
matter all yes what is one of the like
the bigger challenges for
explainability yeah uh so the question
is what is the uh major challenge so I I
mentioned a lot of like unknown things
here like for example counterfactual
explanation you know model level
explanations that are not too clear and
then you know there's like this tradeoff
between conciseness and the Fidelity
metric that's also not very clear and
there are a lot of open Direction I
would say like this is a pretty new area
as you can see like the paper we did was
like 2019 and and last year on the
evaluation so it's a very recent top and
there are like so many challenges I
think uh and one other uh potential
Direction I want to mention is
Generation right uh like can we explain
like say a drug Discovery or like a
generation procedure you know what is
being used by this strategy to generate
graphs um and another aspect is you know
potentially use generative models for
generating this kind of explanation that
are stable and also concise so like I
think a lot of um uh interesting
directions uh we know much less than um
other
fields yes is there any kind of way that
we can incorporate let's say some kind
of inductive bias or understanding of
people from certain
Fields with explainability of GNN so we
don't just expect the models to learn
what we want them and then identify but
actually yeah that's a great question
energetic problem that's a great
question so uh what we uh so the
question is on like whether uh we can
use inductive B from domain experts to
help in explainability um I think what
currently people uh usually want to do
is they extract explanations for the
model and then they ask domain experts
you know how many of these explanations
do you think make sense like what are
things that are that don't make sense is
it because of the model artifact or is
it because there are something that we
haven't discovered in science yet um so
it's usually like um we we have to have
very close uh collaboration human
feedback from the DOI experts see are
this explanation is good if not let's
add more inductive bias and and retrain
this thing right for example like maybe
the expert says I usually think uh think
that this motive is important then um
maybe in in in our explanation we can
like specifically look at those motives
like as an aggregation of these mask
weights and then you look at the weights
there um so it's like a lot of like back
and forth I think uh between the domain
experts and and and what we're doing
um um but yeah like human feedback I
think it's very important that
integrating that it's definitely a good
research
direction
oh to try to generate explanations
explainability for dynamic gra the that
keep having different not or the way is
actually changing yeah that's a great
question as well uh there's one paper on
like Tempo gen explanation I think it's
uh it's either this year I clear or last
year in Europe so it's a very very
recent topic I only see one paper and
we're actually working on another one
that uh does like temporal explanation
the the idea is s of kind also borrow
from like one of the previous I forgot
science and nature paper on the
temporal explain based on the temporal
motives uh the importance score of
every very good
topic maybe all time thank you great job
thank
[Applause]
you